auch leute ist jetzt wieder heute show
aufzeichnen oder was können wir sie
morgen machen hier muss heute seine neue
show
ja das sind die wirklich nichts
vorbereitet ich habe gar nichts jetzt ja
aber kann man gerne machen kann ich
begleiten ich muss noch zur uni
bibliothek ich habe da vergessen ein
buch weg zu bringen
[Musik]
also seit acht jahren wir haben die
mahnung immer an die falsche adresse
geschickt jetzt muss ich 1300 euro
mahngebühren zahlen aber mache ich gerne
nicht mag der wissenschaft also dicke
bücher dicke brillen dicke erkenntnisse
hub
macbooks erkennt den 1 wer liebt sie
nicht
viele sogar sehr viele viele hassen
wissenschaft geradezu
es gibt ja leute die glauben dass die
erde eine scheibe ist und dann gibt es
leute die glauben dass es demokratie ist
wenn auch solche meinungen gehört werden
müssen das ist ein großes
missverständnis
jeder mensch ist gleich viel wert ja
aber nicht jeder meinung ich meine sag
was du willst aber niemand ist
verpflichtet dir zuzuhören
gott sei dank
wenn saskia sagt ihr solltet alle einen
quartz stellen an eurer nase reiben des
hilft gegen krebs will ich vor allem
wissen was hilft gegen saskia
wissenschaftler/innen die haben bei mir
ein vertrauensvorschuss weil sie nichts
anderes machen als sehr viel rum zu
denken um was rauszufinden für jedes mal
dass ich einen schluck aus einem gegners
genommen habe hat christian drosten in
einem mikroskop kopf v das ist wirklich
oft wie sehr kann man via hassen
offenbar hatte der richtig wach auf
erkenntnis da habe ich respekt vor und
ich muss die nicht mal kritisieren weil
ihnen selber machen wissenschaft ist
wien selbstreinigender backofen hinter
jeder wissenschaftlichen arbeit steht
quasi immer ich könne mich aber auch
irren das ist übrigens etwas das du nie
hören wir dass von einem
verschwörungstheoretiker
ich habe herausgefunden angela merkel
ist ein reptil
aber keiner seiner ich mich irre hallo
prüft lieber nochmal nach an tag und ich
habe gerade ein auto ohne maske lackiert
so kann auch wegen der dämpfe seien
verschwörungs quatsch ist nur die spitze
des problems wenn wir jeder meinung egal
wie unsinnig das gehör schenken wird auf
einmal alles verhandelbar das c-leg der
gesellschaft in einer demokratie müssen
wir nicht alle die gleiche position
haben wir müssen auf dem gleichen boden
stehen also wir müssen uns eine grund
realität teilen demokratie ist ja
streiten über die frage wie wollen wir
leben und wenn mal gesagt ich glaube
nicht dass es schwerkraft gibt wie soll
man dann darüber diskutieren was die
beste lösung ist in der
gesundheitspolitik umwelt verkehr
mareike wird dann immer sagen seile
na klar damit wir nicht wegfliegen bull
steht hält uns nicht nur auf wenn man
die eigentlichen themen nicht besprechen
kann er sorgt auch dafür dass leute
desorientiert sind wer so einen unsinn
100 mal sagt hat immer noch nicht recht
aber man bekommt recht in ganz normale
diskussionen schleicht sich auf einmal
bullshit beispielsweise bei der
klimakrise
sorry bei dem optima krise sind jetzt
ein paar leute ausgestiegen ok klären
wir also ihr denkt klimakrise klingt
dramatisch
und ich finde es angemessen die
unabhängige wissenschaftsstiftung
leopoldina sagt das handeln der
menschheit destabilisiert das erdsystem
auf eine weise welche die existenz der
heutigen und kommenden generation sowie
die vielfalt des lebens auf der erde
bedroht schon amtlich klimawandel das
klingt so nett ist nicht alles im wandel
dann kommen wir auch einen waldbrand
einen temperatur wandel nennen also kurz
bevor der komplett in wald abgebrannt
ist würde ich gerne von einer waldbrand
katastrophe sprechen denn bisher hat
niemand gelöscht es gibt ja nach wie vor
einige die sagen es gibt keinen menschen
gemachten klimawandel
ich finde wenn über 90 prozent aller
wissenschaftler innen das seit
jahrzehnten sagen dann ist das so also
du findest bei jedem thema ja ein paar
prozent die anderer meinung sind gegen
eine kneipe und fragt wer von euch
glaubte sonnencreme gar nicht wirkt da
findest du immer einen der sagt
sonnencreme sonnencreme ist nach
hinunter sein industrie
okay wenn jemand von denen ich sag mal
drei prozent klima krisen vorhaben seien
eingeladen wird in der talkshow und eine
andere person für die 97 prozent steht
die die realität anerkennen wird es für
alle die vor dem fernseher sitzen wie
kann man so sehen wir auch so sehen
keine ahnung dann haben wir alle
gewonnen die gerne kohle verbrennen es
entsteht unfall das gleichgewicht und
das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur ein
beliebiges beispiel das passiert es gibt
eine studie die 100000 zeitungsartikel
untersucht hat und festgestellt hat über
eine klimaanlage rinn wird statistisch
gesehen mehr berichtet als über eine
seriöse wissenschaftlerin fake news
verbreiten sich in den sozialen medien
sechsmal schneller als richtige
nachrichten die eintrittskarte ins crazy
land ist immer die frage aber was kannst
du mit sicherheit wissen und die antwort
ist ehrlicherweise nichts aber ich
vertraue manchen neuen dass hier etwas
wissen und es gibt bei manchen sachen
eine große wahrscheinlichkeit dass etwas
stimmt und bei manchen weniger und bei
manchen sachen ist einfach nicht wie zb
brown gab es so unfassbar viele bubble
tea läden und dann plötzlich nicht mehr
ich glaube gegen desinformation hilft
nur massive aufklärung seriöser medien
irgendein hegel wenn sie doch finden das
zweite problem für wissenschaft heißt
anja anja karliczek das ist die
bildungsministerin und ich sage mal so
wenn anni scheuer und anja karliczek
sich darum streiten würden wäre die
goldene wurst für die schlechteste
politik bekommt ich wüsste nicht wer
gewinnt
das bildungsministerium hat vor ein paar
monaten ein video veröffentlicht in dem
eine gut gelaunte comic frau sagt ich
bin anna und ich erzähle euch warum eine
wissenschaftskarriere in deutschland
geiler ist als eine wasserrutsche also
das war zumindest die grundaussage und
unter dem hashtag ich bin hanna haben
dann viele menschen aus dem
wissenschaftsbetrieb geschrieben wie
beschissen ihre situation ist
wenn man an der uni karriere machen will
muss man innerhalb von zwölf jahren
entweder professorin oder professor
werden oder man hat verloren nach zwölf
jahren ist ein schluss und innerhalb
dieser zwölf jahre kennst du dich von
einem befristeten vertrag zum nächsten
du muss umziehen von hamburg nach
ingolstadt du ziehst also wirklich für
zwei jahre nach ingolstadt arbeitest
hart nur damit du dann nach zwei jahren
vielleicht neuen vertrag bekommt der ist
dann aber in speyer usw nur um dann nach
zwölf jahren selbstaufopferung zuhören
und dann bist du raus aus der uni und
das keine arbeit mehr aber erst jetzt
als der gebildete taxifahrer in speyer
durch das land der dichter und denker
der irrglaube ist wenn es nur mehr druck
gibt arbeiten menschen mehr und besser
hey anja karliczek es geht um menschen
deren job denken ist das fällt jetzt
anja karliczek erstmals schwer sich da
rein zu fühlen aber kleiner tipp niemand
denkt besser wenn er angst hat
und wenn wir das alles mal ignorieren
und sagen die uni soll ein unternehmen
sein warum wird sie dann geführt wie das
schlechteste unternehmen der welt also
ich meinen kein konzern würde zwölf
jahre in die ausbildung an der
mitarbeiterin stecken und dann zu sagen
während lassen sie weil sie nicht der
chef geworden sind und wer kann sich
leisten sein komplettes leben auf die
uni einzustellen mit vielen umzügen und
phasen von arbeitslosigkeit reiche oder
kinder von reichen eltern bildung der
luxus und das ist weder kontraproduktiv
weil man nicht eine auswahl unter allen
schlauen köpfen trifft sondern unter
allen reichen köpfen
dichter und denker werden in deutschland
immer dann von konservativen verehrt
wenn sie tot sind tote kosten kein geld
also eigentlich habe ich das buch nicht
vergessen ich wollte mit den 1300 euro
mahngebühren einfach der wissenschaften
bisschen unter die arme greifen so muss
man es so aussehen und ich hoffe dass
sie da wenigstens mal ein bücherregal
nach oder so ich meine ich werde
vorbereitet
als ich mein wenn die uni und
unternehmen ist da kauf ich mich da
gerne ein oder muss auch ein bisschen
was zurückkommen und ich denke mir immer
von herrn doktor ist ob wohl nicht zu
viel verlangt
leute ich weiß bei bildung denken immer
viele partie fiel mit buchstaben super
langweilig wir machen euch davon heute
schon ganz niedrigschwelliges angebot
einfach den kanal abonnieren das ist
lustig oder informativ das bällebad für
euren kopf das furzkissen für die augen
einfach diese videos angucken und dann
abonnieren danke